here's another Perry compilation brought
to you by ochodo TV enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
the content shown in this video has been
submitted by various players to ochodo
TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful owner
extended
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
yeah yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
in ochodo TV send in your clips
following these steps before you submit
your Clips make sure the quality of the
video is clear put your IGN as a file
name for your video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category don't spam
submissions and don't send folders with
your Clips on avoid full-length matches
or just cut the clip you want on the
desired play Until the End of the rant
next send your Clips via Dropbox in the
correct category
find it on the description of every
ochodo TV series Once you upload your
video file if it prompts you to give
your name just put in your IGN
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
[Music]